public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente jean
christophe cambadélis le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste est
l'invité cette semaine de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez vous 2
public sénat avec nous l'avons dit radio
classique et les échos et l' agence
france-presse
c'est au cours de cette émission vous
répondrez à trois grandes questions jean
francis pécresse vous demandera d'abord
dans un instant si françois hollande
pourra se représenter puisque les
sondages on le voit sont toujours très
mauvais ils s'accumulent
deuxième question le cil malandain vous
interrogera ensuite sur la gauche et l
irréconciliable c'est l'image qu'elle
donne plus que jamais en ce moment enfin
mickaël szames s vous demandera si on ne
se dirige pas tout droit vers un nouveau
21 avril un duel droite extrême droite
en 2017 mais d'abord jean christophe
cambadélis une question d'actualité
questions d'actualité
dès que vous devenez français vos
ancêtres sont gaulois a lancé hier soir
nicolas sarkozy en meeting à val d'oise
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
idée
ça fait un peu l'histoire pour les nuls
c'est vrai que sarkozy et cambadélis
s'est totalement gaulois je crois que la
france marche ou mélanges et elle marche
bien parce que vous êtes choqués par
cette formule c'est du sarkozy dans le
texte dans de l'à-peu-près de la
provocation
essayez de faire le buzz autour de lui
on a retrouvé le sarkozy d'avant il nous
fait une petite rechute l'a1 mais que
comme vous il a il est un français de
sang mêlé il le revendique et on est
d'accord et lui donc dit mes ancêtres se
sont gaulois point vous dit vous n'êtes
pas la même chose mais ils sont sept
sont mes ancêtres et il n'était pas
gaulois puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
français
et donc il y a eu un processus
d'intégration dans la société française
tout en gardant un certain nombre
d'éléments culturels je bois sûrement
plus dorée de sina que le lait france le
français moyen et je mange sûrement
beaucoup plus grec que l'ensemble de mes
compatriotes mais ça ne fait pas pour
moi de moi quelqu'un qui n'est pas
assimilé pour reprendre la formule de
nicolas sarkozy alors justement il met
en avant cette notion d'assimilation est
ce qu'il ne faut pas entendre sa sortie
en fait comme un avertissement face au
danger aujourd'hui du multiculturalisme
et face notamment à la poussée du
fondamentalisme musulman dans notre pays
il propose un impact de d'assimilation
sous-entendu que il y à des français
qu'ils ne seraient pas de souche
c'est exactement ce que dit le front
national il n'y a pas de divergence et
même ça le pack d'assimilation jean
marie le pen n'a jamais osé le dire dans
aucun de ses meetings et dans aucune de
ces déclarations tant qu on voit
jusqu'où on est arrivé nicolas sarkozy
pour essayer de faire venir à lui
l'électorat frontiste jeudi que tout
ceci est un danger pour la france parce
que cela met l amène à jeter les
français les uns contre les autres
est ce que vous êtes français vous
n'êtes pas français votre culture n'est
pas française s'est pas de ça qu'il faut
c'est la cohésion nationale et ensemble
à
fonté les problèmes donc vous nous dites
qu'en fait le front national est débordé
sur son extrême droite par nicolas
sarkozy avec cette phrase sur nos
ancêtres les gaulois mme pas sur cette
phrase sur les ancêtres les oies sur son
pacte d'assimilation mais je crois oui
que le cours actuel de nicolas sarkozy
qui est de construire un programme
commun entre une droite extrême et une
extrême droite
il est en train qui arrivait d'ailleurs
tout le monde à droite s'aligne sur lui
personne ne peut résister dans ce
domaine et vous avez vu les déclarations
depuis ce matin jean christophe
cambadélis
il y a beaucoup de distance prise par
tous les autres candidats à la primaire
dans les 100 a terminé juppé je pense à
bruno le maire sur la formule les
gaulois elle est tellement caricaturale
que les criminels dans son camp les
critiques et sur cette formule mais pour
le reste
pour le reste sur tous les sujets tout
le monde s'aligne sur nicolas sarkozy
juppé a sur ce terrain là une un
alignement complet il l'a dit dans
valeurs actuelles
ce week-end il a indiqué que dans les
mesures du regroupement familial ou le
reste il l'avait dit avant nicolas
sarkozy donc on ne peut pas dire dans la
danse non je n'entend aucune nouvelle
quand vous avez tout le loisir et juppé
c'est les frères siamois d'une même
politique
pas d'accord mais petit tout le monde
vient sur les positions de nicolas
sarkozy j'ai envie de vous demander
parce que ça n'est pas le cas de manuel
valls à l'heure parce que lui aussi
parle beaucoup d'identité parler
d'identité
ce n'est pas d'hier que il y a des gens
qui ne sont pas français parlé d'
identité c'est parler de la république
s'il parlait de la france ça je suis
prêt mais on voit bien que la
connotation qui est déployée derrière ce
vocable d'identité c'est d'indiquer
qu'il y à des français de souche et des
français de papier en tous les cas ce
mot assimilation vous le rejetez vous
préférez celui d intégration mais
monsieur même si l'annulation rose et
même si l'opération est un échec mais il
est passé pas un échec l'intégration il
ya de merveilleux exemple de réussite
mais globalement mais ce n'est pas
globalement un échec même dans les
sondages que qui aujourd'hui sorte on
voit bien que la main
joe rites et des hommes et des femmes
s'estiment français quelles que soient
leurs origines 75% d'entre eux même
façon sans cesse on n'est pas méchants
sondage soit voilà sur les musulmans les
musulmans donc ce n'est pas un échec
c'est une réussite mais c'est nous qui
projetons sur une infime minorité de
d'intégristes ou de salafistes ce que
serait toute la communauté de culture ou
du culte musulman très bien premier
grand thème maintenant de l'épreuve de
vérité
jean christophe cambadélis et c'est jean
francis pécresse des échos et de radio
classique que nous accueillons
maintenant l'épreuve de vérité
les critiques les 6es l'isiq au pouvoir
en france et pour ce faire michel
bonsoir jean christophe cambadélis
alors votre question au premier
secrétaire du ps lorsque vous voyez les
cotes de popularité les courbes
d'intentions de vote est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que françois hollande
sera en capacité de se présenter à la
présidence de la république
tout dépend de lui c'est pas les
sondages qui vont décider c'est lui qui
décidera s'il est candidat ou pas et
s'il décide d'être candidat même s'il ya
des mauvais sondages
il sera candidat et très mauvais
sondages très mauvais sondages mais il y
à des sondages dans une période où dans
un moment où personne ne connaît les
candidats personne ne connaît les
programmes et simplement 30% des
français s'intéressent à la
présidentielle alors je sais que pour
les médias
c'est embêtant mais c'est la réalité
donc il faudrait parler du fait que
aujourd'hui les français ne sont pas
dans la présidentielle
on n'est pas candidat que par envie par
choix on est candidat parce qu'on sent
dans l'opinion une aspiration une
véritable envie est ce que vous sentez
chez les français une envie de françois
hollande ans quand les bons candidats
lovren en tire avec françois on n'est
pas candidat pour une envie chez les
français on l'a su site on est candidat
parce qu'on a un dessin pour la france
ça c'est la définition à ce projet dès
la définition du général de gaulle qui à
l un des ces institutions dialogue entre
un homme et
un destin un dessein pour son peuple
le projet vous le dira s'il est candidat
il va le développer je le suppose
dans un entretien récent au quotidien le
monde et à la revue des bars à françois
hollande dit être porteur d'une france
fraternelle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
être porteur d'une france fraternelle et
qui peut le croire quand la france sort
de mouvements aussi rude que les
mouvements contre la manif pour tous où
les manifestations contre la loi travail
mais on peut manifester est fraternelle
ce n'est pas contradictoire
la fraternité la fraternité l'aï telle
que nous la concevons c'est la
possibilité du vivre ensemble c'est une
autre manière de poser le vivre ensemble
nous estimons qu'ils avaient parié sur
une société apaisée ça fait mal car elle
n'est pas apaisé parce qu'elle a été par
percuter par le terrorisme pas parce
qu'il n'a pas pu l'apaiser reprenons
nous nous avons une divergence majeure
majeur qui fait tout un proche un projet
de société avec la droite et l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui sur ce que doit être
la france nous nous voulons une france
fraternelle
nous voulons pas de césure au milieu de
la france nous ne désignons pas une
partie de la population comme étant les
fauteurs de trouble ou dix ans pour
reprendre un certain nombre de formules
que la france a un programme problème
avec eux ça c'était effectivement
c'était effectivement le discours de la
salle wagram ça n'a eu aucun effet dans
l'opinion publique quand on lit encore
une fois les sondages de popularité et
les sondages d'intentions de vote est à
dire que geste après geste il ne se
passe pour françois hollande rien comme
si les français l'avait zapper en
quelque sorte est ce que ça ne vous
inquiète pas quand mais je ne pense pas
ces discours infuse
ils sont des éléments de référence nous
les diffusons nous faisons en sorte
qu'il soit entendu réparer la chaux
christophe cambadélis aveugle et moi
jamais je suis assez irréaliste assez
clair maintenant mais il réaliste c'est
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec vous
non je suis réaliste par rapport à
l'analyse que je me fais de la situation
politique la droite via son référence
aux primaires ne réglera pas son
problème stratégique y aura deux
candidats de droite
vers et l'extrême droite est à un niveau
que l'on n'a jamais vu en france il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont se passer
jusqu'à l'exception présidentielle et je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus ouvert
qu'on veut bien le dire
est ce que les conseillers des cabinets
ministériels n'ont pas eu déjà voté en
quelque sorte puisqu'il apparemment ils
fuient les cabinets 10% des effectifs
sont déjà partis et ne sont pas
remplacés
est-ce que ça n'est pas un signe très
inquiétant du pur sang s'est pas agi
pour cent et pas excessif
et vous savez c'est également réagi ça
c'est le titre du monde qui a fait sa
campagne
non c'est pas hémorragie il avait
quasiment la même chose à la fin de
sarkozy bon alors il prévoyait aussi la
défaite de ce dernier peut-être
non je crois que c'est normal sauve qui
peut sauf qu'il a dit des conneries à
l'elysée pour cent sauf qu'ils peuvent
non vous savez un sauve qui peut c'est
90% ce qui n'est pas le cas mais ce
n'est pas anormal vu le fait que l' on
le dit du matin jeu ce soir
les jeux sont faits c'est le banat peine
d'aller voter la droite est qualifiée
est ce que le président on est dans mon
nez dans cette situation aujourd'hui on
nous dit marine le pen
pas de problème est au 2e tour la droite
et le et au deuxième tour il ne reste
plus qu'à la gauche d'essayer de
soutenir le candidat républicain
moi je vous dis ça ne se passera pas
comme ça parce que les français vont
voter là comme sûre quel bilan sur un
bilan contrasté qui pourra être présenté
aux français et ste bilan
moi je veux le confronter aux projets de
la droite sur tous les sujets un bilan
contrasté c'est d'ailleurs ici de mâcon
soit et ça veut dire que tu as réussi
sur du mauvais pas du mauvais on n'a pas
réussi sur tout mais on a réussi à
redresser la france et c'est un élément
je crois extrêmement positif mais nous
sommes là dans l'absolu c'est à dire
pour terminer les sondages d'aujourd'hui
qui est contre le gouvernement prenons
les choses très simplement
l'extrême droite 30% les républicains 30
à 35%
l'extrême gauche 10 à 12% et une partie
de la gauche des frondeurs qui sont je
sais pas combien disons si on prend les
derniers sondages pour montreux bourg
entre 5 et 7%
comment voulez vous dans ces conditions
là
tu nous soyons majoritaire ne le sommes
pas donc le jour où il y aura trois ou
quatre candidats ils auront leur
programme ils auront ce qu'ils ont fait
et il dit pourront qu on pourra comparer
les français comparent rond dans
l'éducation nationale ce que nous avons
fait et ce qu'on nous propose de faire
ils compareront sur la question du tiers
payant ce que nous avons fait et ce que
la droite veut défaire et ainsi de suite
à mon avis ça changera la vision des
français
tout le monde le sais françois hollande
avait lié sa candidature à une inversion
de la courbe du chômage
bon depuis le début de l'année 2016 le
chômage en france baisse de 75 mille
personnes baissé de 75 et personne n'en
reste pas moins que depuis le mois de
mai 2012
on a un solde positif de 5 185 mille
chômeurs en plus que nous avons un taux
de chômage de 9 et demi pour cent que en
ce moment même
l'allemagne est à moins de six que le
royaume uni est à 5e la suisse est à 3
est ce que ce bilan la peut lui
permettre de se représenter devant les
français de manière sérieuse tout à fait
parce qu'il a engagé un processus de
baisse du chômage qui les liera teach
vous le concède mais qui est une
tendance et qui a été très fortement
annoncé chez les jets les plus jeunes
même si dans d'autres catégories
nous sommes à rester à des niveaux qui
ne sont pas acceptables
on peut se comparer avec nos partenaires
vous savez très bien que en allemagne ou
en angleterre le le travail partiel le
travail pour un euro ou 2 euros ou 10
euros est un travail qui est extrêmement
répandu prétendre avoir inversé la
courbe du chômage
menant nous avons nous pouvons prétendre
nous pouvons prétendre avoir réussi à
remettre la france sur les rails du
point de vue de la lutte contre le
chômage donc de la croissance donc de la
création d'emplois parce qu'on ne dis
jamais jamais que aujourd'hui le pari du
chef de l'état ait perdu dans le paris
du chef de l'état n'est pas totalement
gaye peut gagner mais il est bien engagé
donc que l'inversion elle reste encore à
faire mais l'inversion total elle reste
à faire évidemment mais vous voyez bien
comment nous sommes engagés et vous
savez je ne pense pas que les français
seront
à ce point critique tel que le sont les
journalistes est telle que le sont les
sondeurs parce que ils se souviendront
de la situation dans laquelle la droite
nous a laissé le pays et ils verront
qu'on a fait les efforts sur nous mêmes
au niveau de l'état qu'on a engagé le
pays dans une bonne question sur le taux
des prélèvements obligatoires c'est à
dire le montant total des impôts des
taxes des charges etc qui restent à 44
et demi pour cent c'est un niveau
pratiquement record il n'a pratiquement
pas baissé il a même augmenté un peu
depuis le début du quinquennat
2 du quinquennat de françois hollande ça
veut dire que le choc fiscal est là
toujours mais nous sommes en train de
rendre aux français ça soit parce que
non on leur a emprunté sar n'a pas dans
les choix
pourquoi on l'a fait c'est parce que
nous on a décidé qu'il fallait augmenter
les impôts
par idéologie ou par construction non
c'est parce que nous avions des déficits
colossaux laissé par la droite et qu'on
n'allait pas laisser le pays à la
banqueroute fillon avait dit je suis
confronté un pays qui n'a plus d'argent
en caisse
nous en avons remis alors françois
hollande et à l'onu aujourd'hui à new
york et hier soir c'est l'heureux
également de son bilan diplomatique et
hier soir il a reçu le prix de l'homme
d'état de l'année donc ce qui a provoqué
cette réaction ce matin
écoutez de bruno le maire s'était sur
radio classique et vous réagirez j'ai du
mal à comprendre qu'on puisse remettre à
un prix d'homme d'état de l'année un
françois hollande
sauf à ce que ce soit une private joke
ou de l'inde aux states enfin quelque
chose comme de l'humour britannique que
j'ai pas toujours très bien si il y
avait du mourre corrézien est ce que
c'est de l'humour britannique
écoutez ce sont les américains qui ont
décidé ce n'est pas ce n'est pas nous et
ça m'étonne pas que la prétention de
monsieur le maire s'exerce vis-à-vis de
nos alliés il fut un temps où directeur
de cabinet de monsieur de villepin il
n'avait pas cette attitude vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires et monsieur cameron
puisqu'il parle des anglais était son
principal allié on voit où cela a mené
tout le monde questions sur le plan
prisons présenté ce matin par jean
jacques urvoas
cet après midi michel sapin ministre de
l'économie ministre du budget a dit niet
il n'y aura pas de rallonge de 1
milliard et demi pour faire les 10000 à
7000 places en plus que monsieur que le
ministre de la justice vous voulez faire
est ce que ça vous est ce que vous le
comprenez est ce que vous appelez bercy
a relâché un peu les les cordons de la
bourse
il y à un débat entre ministres c'est au
premier ministre de l'arbitré pas au
premier secrétaire mais il me semble que
le premier ministre a parlé de la
nécessité de créer dix mille postes si
l'on peut appeler ça des postes 10
places en prison que si le premier
ministre l'a dit il n'est pas anormal
que le ministre de la justice travail
réfléchissent sur cette voie après y'a
un arrimage budgétaire a fait donc la
question de jean francis pour commencer
c'est est ce que françois hollande
pourra se représenter on a compris votre
réponse oui c'est à dire que pour
l'inciter à le faire donc un vous avez
déjà les arguments là tout près moi je
crois que le président de la république
peut se présenter et qu'il doit se
présenter et que ceci est nécessaire
pour la france voilà mon raisonnement
très bien merci
jean-francis pécresse deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité avec lucile
malandain de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint maintenant l'épreuve de
vérité avec l'eye fi
bonsoir lucile montfort mont saint
michel manche toi c'est comme un délice
votre question au premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste alors manuel valls
avait prédit il y a quelques mois nous
sommes maintenant à sept mois de la
présidentielle la gauche et l
irréconciliable mois ces débats m'amuse
un peu parce que pour moi la gauche et
réconciliables depuis 1920 partir du
moment où il ya eu la scission entre les
sociaux démocrates socialistes et les
communistes
elle est irréconciliable la question qui
est posée c'est qu'est ce que est ce qu
elle peut ou pas s'unir à des moments
donnés quand c'est l'histoire l'histoire
a montré que mais quand nous étions unis
nous étions tout autant il
réconciliables nous avions des dvd
divergences majeures
on n'a jamais vu un parti unique de
l'ensemble de la gauche je lé souhaitait
un moment donné j'ai constaté que ce
n'était pas possible
les communistes resteront communistes
les écologistes resteront ceux des
écologistes et les socialistes resteront
socialiste ça me paraît normal ils ont
une culture de gouvernement que n'ont
pas les autres c'est ce qui fait les
difficultés du rassemblement mais quand
il s'agit de s'unir
regardez dans les collectivités locales
ils s'unissent ils sont ils travaillent
ensemble et depuis très très longtemps
malgré les divergences dans la
présidentielle
y'a pas à s'unir dans la présidentielle
parce qu'il y en a qu'un qui est élu
après c'est dans les législatives c'est
un autre débat et gym assemblée là aussi
d'entendre pire laurent à la fête de
l'humanité ne pas écarter la possibilité
ici ou là de trouver des accords avec le
parti socialiste qui a mis très en
colère d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon
parlant d'une stratégie dans 577
circonscriptions
donc ils ont des désaccords entre eux je
sais pas s'ils sont irréconciliables
mais en tout état de cause il y en a qui
veulent discuter avec nous par les
législatives d'autres qui refusent alors
justement puisque vous parlez de perdre
on va l'écouter parce que ça n'est pas
simple non plus de leur côté vous avez
raison de le souligner jean christophe
cambadélis le communiste pierre laurent
a
du mal à rejoindre jean-luc mélenchon
mais écoutez sa détermination néanmoins
ce matin c'était dans territoire d'infos
sur public sénat sa détermination
vis-à-vis de du quinquennat qui s'achève
nous voyons bien que dans la situation
actuelle
si nous n'allons pas vers la convergence
et le rassemblement des forces de gauche
qui veulent tourner la page de l'échec
du quinquennat de françois hollande
eh bien nous risquons aller à une
catastrophe politique voilà la question
que nous posons et que nous allons
continuer à poser avec force et ça n'est
pas une défiance à l'égard de tel ou tel
dans ses forces de gauche c'est juste
une interpellation forte parce que nous
sommes inquiets pour le pays et nous
pensons que la convergence de ces forces
est nécessaire il a il s'adresse
mais comment très sévère mais il en
jugeant très possible non les français
attendent c'est un peu enlevée dans la
prière c'est impossible pour le sait
tout c'est impossible pour lui vous
savez c'était aussi impossible de
s'allier avec claude bartolone lors des
élections régionales ça n'a pas empêché
notre ami sénateurs de le faire donc
mais donc les formules impossible ça
leur est dire qu ils pensent la même
chose à 2 de son parti là je peux faire
un primaire avec les socialistes
j'ai compris le candidat pas soutenir le
candidat socialiste mais à un moment
donné on va le confronter au programme
de la droite ou de l'extrême droite et
et admettons si on était face à
l'extrême droite ils soutiendraient pas
le candidat socialiste allons tout ça
c'est une manière de pouvoir discuter
pour essayer de rassembler toutes les
forces qui ne sont pas d'accord avec le
parti socialiste
moi j'aime il dit votre organe et des
circonscriptions pour gagner déçu
reconstruction pour exercer un rapport
devant vous savez depuis la rupture du
programme commun avec georges marchais
la stratégie du parti communiste a
toujours effet été d'essayer de refaire
en sorte que le parti communiste comme
dans son ancien temps passe devant le
parti socialiste
d'ailleurs jean luc mélenchon a été
exactement la même orientation il s'agit
pas de battre la droite et l'extrême
droite mais de faire en sorte que une
formation politique passe devant le
parti socialiste
combien ils le feraient ça changerait
quoi on sera bien obligé de s'unir alors
parlons de votre primaires parce qu'on a
l'impression quand même que les contours
sont encore assez flou il ya des
interrogations chez certains candidats
emporte d'arnaud montebourg dans le dal
dans le même sens est ce que le ps lui
tout seul et réconciliables est ce que
aujourd'hui les frondeurs il ya de
multiples candidatures
benoît un noir de monde vous pour marie
noëlle lienemann gérard filoche
est ce que est ce que ça va être
possible de faire partie alors de faire
participer françois hollande à la même
primaires c'est la décision que vous
avez prise mais ce que ça va être
possible de le faire sans y laisser trop
de plumes un faux le ps je crois si on
fait si on suit notre débat et le
précédent attentes et a indiqué que nous
avions perdu énormément de plus donc je
n'ai pas peur de la confrontation
je pense qu'elle peut être salutaire
pourquoi parce que en fin de compte dans
cette primaire nous aurons toutes les
positions de la gauche et c'est une
primaire de toute la gauche par
l'intermédiaire de des candidats
socialistes
d'un certain point de vue toutes les
positions de la gauche seront
représentés des écologistes des
socialistes critiquent ou des
socialistes défendent ans et pour cause
la politique gouvernementale
donc à partir de là nous aurons la
possibilité de trancher sur qui sera le
candidat est ce que nous ferons mais ce
que ça n'est pas humiliant pour le chef
de l'état que de la ligne est dans une
compétition
à côté de ces candidats dans la liste
vient d'être rappelé par les connexions
sont quand même pourquoi ce serait
illuminé on va d'abord parce que c'est
le président sortant du bar à six pieds
cet exercice première argument c'est un
exercice démocratique mais il ne s'agit
pas de dieu ou de dieuze descendants de
l'olympe
là il s'agit d'un président de la
république est un président la
république qui a été attaqué par tout le
monde du rallye qui met les mets donc
vous avez une contradiction
soit vous dit tu le président de la
république à 15 % ou à 10% ne peut pas
se représenter soit à 15% et 10% il
n'est pas populaire dans l'ensemble
de l'opinion et donc s'il se représente
il va pas m'être mis en cause parce
qu'il va débattre avec benoît hamon ou
arnaud montebourg il y aura un débat
il sera ou pas eu encore faut-il qu'il
soit candidat et puis à partir de là
tout le monde se rassemblera pour moi la
primaire c'est un moyen de rassembler
parce que s'il n'y a pas de primaires il
y aura des candidats à l'extérieur de la
primaire et à ce moment là je sais
surtout de ce qui va se passer avec 4%
ou 5%
on ne sera pas au deuxième tour arnaud
montebourg dit encore aurait hier soir
quelconque filtrer sur françois hollande
aujourd'hui pour quelque chose
chauffer la salle de ses meetings
comment est-ce que vous réagissez quand
vous entendez ce là haut un peu
d'humilité quand on est à 3% ou 4% les
sondages ne fait pas de mal et un petit
peu plus quatre passes en cinq ans tous
les cas sa campagne dont elle ne prend
pas pourquoi parce qu'elle est
exclusivement dirigées contre le chef de
l'état si elle était un peu plus
dirigées contre la droite et l'extrême
droite peut-être que l'électorat de
gauche qui s'inquiètent des divisions
prêterait une oreille attentive à ceux
qui contestent la politique
gouvernementale mais là encore une fois
il ne s'agit pas de d'avoir un candidat
qui pourrait gagner contre la droite
il s'agit soit d'empêcher le président
de la république soit de faire en sorte
qu'ils trébuchent
cette stratégie punitive et d'une
stratégie qui ne prend pas dans
l'opinion la main en attendant arnaud
montebourg essaye d'imposer quand même
un certain nombre de conditions à
l'organisation de ces primaires
notamment en demandant qu'elle soit
organisée sur le même modèle qu'en 2011
où elle n'était pas du tout le même
contexte où en êtes vous sur cette
organisation est ce que vous avez déjà
décider de la manière dont pour obtenir
ses parrainages de la répartition des
bureaux de vote
le nombre de bureaux de vote je peux
vous rassurer là dessus
nous avons beaucoup avancé en termes de
bureaux de vote
et en termes de parrainage en termes de
texte commun à l'ensemble des candidats
on est entre 7500 et 8000 et ils sont
répartis comme en 2011 ils sont répartis
comme en 2011 mais oh moi je propose
qu'on l'est concentre un peu plus qu'en
2011 dans les endroits où il y avait un
fort où il y a un fort vote de gauche ça
sert strictement rien à rien de mettre
énormément de bureaux de vote dans des
endroits où c'est ultra majoritaire à
droite c'est rien c'est pour faire de
l'affichage ont fait de l'affichage
moi je n'ai pas de problème à mettre des
bureaux de vote un peu partout en
particulier dans les fédérations
dirigé par les amis d'un os montebourg
qui sont pas très allants aujourd'hui
dans leur remontée
du point de vue de des bureaux de vote
mais ça va venir
bon et puis après voilà on en organise
les parrainages ils savent c'est 5% de
parlementaires ou 5 % de ville de 10000
on connaisse tous les tenants et les
aboutissants il ya le petit texte qui
dit fusion des deux textes sur les
salles et quand ils sont visés mais on
se réunit toutes les semaines ils sont
tous là autour de la table vous savez
tous les candidats vingt les
représentants vous savez les grandes
opérations sont levés mais il ya les
grandes déclarations pour la presse
c'est d'ailleurs pour dire tu on n'est
pas tous d'accord avec le parti
socialiste histoire de gagner des voix
dans les sondages
et puis il ya la réalité sur le terrain
je peux même vous dire que les intitulés
d'arnaud montebourg maintenant pour
tenir ses réunions c'est participer à la
réunion autour d'arnaud montebourg
candidat à la primaire de la gauche
voilà d'accord ont été rassurés sur la
joyeuse
j'en suis persuadé si je lis les textes
qui sont distribués dans un certain
nombre de départements
c'est qu'il s'est fait entendu un autre
un autre une autre personnalité qui
appartenait au gouvernement de françois
hollande qui mais qui n'a jamais
appartenu au père est je crois
emmanuel macron et
alors lui vous pose un autre problème si
je puis dire puisque il refuse de
participer à la primaire a priori donc
c'est pas non plus il va être candidat
ça vous allez l'invité je suppose il va
vous répondre avec plaisir mais pour
l'instant il est ni de droite ni de
gauche
bon donc il peut pas participer à une
primaire de gauche c'est à lui de
décider si d'un seul coup et on y trouve
que en fin de compte la gauche c'est sa
famille et qu'il n'est pas anormal dû
participer à une primaire il nous le
dira et on regardera comment on peut
faire mais pour l'instant il a choisi un
chemin qui n'est pas celui que nous
avons collectivement et alors et si
françois hollande décide de ne pas se
présenter
est-ce que emmanuel mâcon pour être le
candidat du parti socialiste
il y aura une primaire si françois
hollande ne veut pas ou ne peut pas ou
ne souhaitent pas se présenter à ce
moment là il y aura sûrement croyez moi
c'est le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste qui vous parle
plusieurs candidats ayant à une primaire
on dégagera le candidat qui nous
permettra de nous réunir
manuel valls semble se préparer
on est en position laisse sans tendance
assez facilement maintenant valu le vase
d'abord et avant tout soutient le
président de la république
et comme tout le monde c'est à dire
comme macro comme comme montebourg ou
comme peut-être d'autres dont on ne
parle pas encore à ce moment ils se
disent s'il n'y allez pas est ce que moi
je ne pourrais pas y aller ce n'est pas
anormal puisque le président ne respecte
n'a rien dit est ce qu est le jour où
elle durable ça sera fini vous souhaitez
que manuel valls il ya ici françois
hollande ne va pas c'est à lui de se
décider moi j'ai pas de souhaits à faire
là franchement jamais je vous voyais
comme un recours non gaap et me faites
pas dire ce que je valais le dire il le
dit c'est très bien c'est normal pour
l'instant pour moi la question
essentielle c'est d'organiser les
primaires et dans les primaires même si
je veux être impartial je souhaite que
le président de la république sans gamme
gagne ces primaires s'engage dans
l'élection présidentielle parce que je
ne doute pas que les français seront
faire un choix positif donc pour vous la
gauche et réconciliables pour répondre à
la question de ce deuxième partie de
l'émission mais elle est capable de
s'unir et galloises et même si françois
hollande a théorisé vous avez vu dans
cet entretien au débat dont on parlait
tout à l'heure avec jean francis et là
il a dénoncé les procureurs de
l'alternative ce sont eux qui ont pour
but dit-il d'empêcher de gouverner un
bien sûr mais il a toujours existé salue
la position et la position du parti
communiste lors du programme commun les
français iront toujours réussi à garder
la gauche unie pas tout le temps paraît
tout le temps maintenant auront donc une
fois à portion que ça prend aujourd'hui
soit en la battant sévèrement en 1981
battons pas le parti communiste
sévèrement 280 et en faisant que cadres
communistes rentrer dans le gouvernement
la dernière fois que nous avons gouverné
ensemble c'était la majorité plurielle
avec lionel jospin
on a fait des tas de choses ensemble on
avait un bon bilan il présent quand même
présenter contre lionel jospin ce qui
nous a valu jacques chirac
voilà donc les empêcheurs merci beaucoup
lui s'il maintenant c'est mickaël ms de
public sénat qui arrivent pour la
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
michel bossé comme un délit si notre
faim alors si on comprend bien de la
question qui nous est posée aujourd'hui
c'est à par la droite
regardez tout ce qu'il nous faut il
comparer regarder la droite et la gauche
mais si je comprends bien à part dire au
secours la droite revient il n'y a rien
d'autre
mais c'est déjà essentiel parce que la
droite revient et en plus elle prévient
sur un programme que l'on n'a jamais vu
un programme mais d'abord
honnêtement on y viendra puisque vous
interrogerez le chaque candidat ce
programme il est il réalisable
il est tellement violent que tellement
violent sur le plan économique je
devrais bras comment est ce qui se
passerait ben je vais dire d'abord on
explose les déficits serait formidable
ceux qui nous ont reproché de ne pas
juguler les déficits
aujourd'hui 10 bon allez on y va on s'en
fiche de toute façon on verra bien
comment on s'arrangera avec une rolex
elle c'est un peu ce que vous dites
comment et ça rejoint bruxelles
oui ceci dit on s'arrangera avec
bruxelles ils s'arrangeront pas du tout
deuxièmement ils sont en train d'emmener
la france dans la situation s'il était
élu qui était celle que nous avons
connue c'est à dire que quand nous
sommes arrivés aux affaires
nicolas sarkozy nous a laissé une france
où on était entre bruxelles qui devait
pouvais faire prendre un certain nombre
de mesures sur l'état le fmi estimé que
la france pouvait être à nouveau sous
son égide et des mouvements sociaux qui
me était prêt à surgir sur chaque
instant il a fallu petit à petit
redresser la france
oui mais là aussi vous avez fait le coup
de l'héritage vous aussi des organes
vous feront peut-être pareil mais ils
nous feront exactement la chose sauf que
nous on leur laissera une situation un
peu plus saine objectivement et oui
d'orbey écoutez moi je prendrais
simplement ce que disent qu'ils
organisent de 2017 2018 devrait
véritablement c'est pas ce que dit la
droite mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
michel sapin et christian eckert ont
fait une conférence de presse
ils ont répondu point par point à ces
accusations
c'est un camouflage de la part de la
droite pour qu'on ne parle pas de leur
déficit mais il n'ya pas que les
déficits
ils vont
revenir sur tout ce qu'on a fait tout à
part le mariage pour tous parce qu'ils
ne trouvaient que c'était un peu chaud
encore qu'il ya des candidats qu'ils y
soient favorables mais ils vont venir
surtout ce qu'on sur tout ce qu'on a
fait le tiers payant le le le combat
qu'on a mené pour redresser l'école la
création de poste trois cent mille
fonctionnaires en moins et c'est à vous
croyez que ça va se faire tranquillement
comme cela donc ils vont mettre bien
c'est suffisant je ne dis pas que c'est
suffisance c'est l'essentiel
oui elle revient et elle prévient voilà
c'est ce qui coûte français doivent
comprendre petit à petit vont le
comprendre
après il y aura un programme il y aura
des propositions pour le prochain
quinquennat on va pas rien se tourner
les pouces en disant ce qu'on a fait
c'était formidable
il arrive pour le défaire de l'image est
là comment fera pas campagne sur un
bilan mais on intégrera notre bilan vous
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure un de vos
collègues
on présentera notre bilan par rapport à
leur projet c'est très facile à faire je
le fais tous les week-ends en meeting ça
marche très très bien
à chaque fois on dit ce qu'on a fait et
on prend au choix
sarkozy juppé un des frères dalton là on
l'a ou pas non non non non non parce que
les cats pour moi c'est les frères
dalton chaque dupas qui est jouable
je me mets donc donc donc giro prend
comme salt est relativement sûr l'un et
l'autre et puis on voit bien que
honnêtement les gens sont convaincus sur
le programme économique est ce qu'il n'a
pas eu qui trouve grâce à vos yeux qui
soit allez on va dire crédible
raisonnable mais ils sont pas
raisonnables pour qui parce qu'ils sont
dans une primaire
donc ils pensent que pour gagner l'après
midi et la primaire il faut aller plus à
droite que moi tu meurs aujourd'hui je
finisse peuvent définissent parce que
marine le pen est en tenue de camouflage
et cetera mais finissent par dépasser
dans les mots marine le pen sur
l'ensemble des sujets aujourd'hui elle
parle pas de pass in chrétienne dit oui
à des racines chrétiennes mais qu'on
était laïcisé par l'universalisme
évidemment qu'elles se cachaient peut
pas aller devant les français avec le
programme qui est le sien
alors elle a des arguments que vous
allez écouter vous allez pouvoir
répondre puisque elle ne parlait ce
matin du front national et d'elle-même
en se disant eh bien de droite et de
gauche
il est évident que vous retrouverez
madame dans le gouvernement qui sera le
mien des gens qui viendront du front
national mais peut-être aussi des gens
qui nous auront rejoint sur les grands
axes de défense de la patrie de la
nation parce que moi je crois qu'il y a
des je crois qu'il ya des patriotes de
droite et de gauche
voilà et quand nous disons nous sommes
ni de droite ni de gauche on pourrait
dire nous sommes et de droite et de
gauche
alors non mais ni de droite ni de gauche
ni de droite et de gauche extrême droite
je sais que ça va quand même pas ça mais
c'est extrême droite c'est à dire que le
ce qui fonde le front national ce
qu'elle ne peut pas gommer
c'est un souverainisme xénophobe il n'y
aurait rien de gauche au front national
et rien de gauche la programme
économique mais moi je vais pas tomber
dans la comparaison du front national
vous croyez que c'est franchement sur
les tels que mesures qui se sont
présentés sur le plan économique que les
gens votent pour le front national
ou c'est par rapport à ce qu'ils agitent
vis-à-vis de l'immigration où les
réfugiés et du reste enfin poser des
questions et faites comme moi du porte à
porte
vous verrez quand les portes du front
national sourd ce que l'on vous dit ce
que l'on vous dit pas c'est ce qu'on
vous raconte pas c'est la csg ou
l'augmentation des impôts encore on vous
le dit sa mère c'est plutôt sur le fait
que notre pays est envahi
c'est ça le fond de commerce du front
national arrivé sur christophe
cambadélis tu au nom du peuple
qu'est ce que vous lui répondait au nom
du peuple non moi je dis au nom des
français c'est un mot d'ordre creux la
france libre et le sujet et oui c'est
s'est opposé le peuple aux élites
bon tu vas pour moi c'est un vieux
programmes démagogue populiste qui vise
à dire que le peuple en lui même à
toutes les vérités et que les élites
sont là pour pervertir
qui serait nécessaire pour le peuple ne
s'est pas mon orientation c'est parce
que je pense je crois qu'il faut
rassembler les français quelle que soit
leur position dans la société
vous parlez des réfugiés qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la levée de boucliers que
l'on constate aujourd'hui parmi les
candidats les républicains et les élus
locaux qui est en veille notamment au
ministre de l'intérieur parce que il
n'ya pas de concertation a priori sur
l'implantation des réfugiés de la jungle
de cette question très importante parce
que nous avons monsieur wauquiez qui a
lancé une pétition contre le
démantèlement de la jungle
alors que monsieur tu le président de la
région
bertrand voilà j'y arrive de la demande
et puis vous avez le front national qui
a créé une association sur le même sujet
donc on voit bien là que les deux
positions se chevauchent ou se
rapprochent
moi ce que je vous dis c'est que le
gouvernement est sans peut pas lui
reprocher cherche à régler les problèmes
la jungle de calais il ya à peine huit
jours
tous les éditorialistes nous disait que
c'était une honte
il fallait régler ce problème on règle
ce problème et on nous dit on mais quand
même vous réglez ce problème en imposant
des gens dans un certain nombre
d'endroits bah oui à partir du moment où
un certain nombre de partis politiques
dont les républicains représentés à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat disent
qu'ils ne le feront pas défaut la nausée
mais bien sûr mais bien sûr il faut
l'imposer
parce que cette répartition ça peut pas
être quand même que les socialistes ou
les hommes et les femmes de gauche
si vous recevoir vous pensez de ces
populations que vous la poser comme
coach et des réquisitions et on peut le
faire sur des lieux sans lequel on peut
mettre en attendant soit qu'il soit
utiliser le droit d'asile soit qu'ils
soient renvoyés dans leur pays
ouais franchement il ya aucun problème
sinon quand cet accès trop ce qu'il ya
une sinon c'est trop simple cet
autoritarisme ça sur les élus locaux
mais elle n'est pas de l'autoritarisme
c'est de la solidarité nationale
vous avez une question tout à l'heure
sur le front national si on permettait
d'y revenir seul instant le fn prêt à
aider jean luc mélenchon obtenir ses
parrainages ce matin marine le pen sur
une radio ne dit pas non ça vous choque
je crois que ça a choqué jean luc
mélenchon si j'ai bien lu l'humanité du
jour et je le comprends c'est une
tentative d'empêcher jean luc mélenchon
de de devenir sur le terrain du
populisme je crois que c'est ça dont un
outil qu'il ya derrière tout ça
franchement croyez que c'est la hauteur
de la situation c'est très très très
politicien rekom les marine le pen
certains font un parallèle entre les
propositions du front national et celle
de jean luc mélenchon entre la france
libre donc revendiquée par la présidente
du front national est soumise est ce que
vous vous voyez des points communs non
c'est beaucoup quand je vois pas de
points communs entre les uns et les
autres
c'est une
formation d'extrême droite un
souverainisme un nationalisme xénophobe
jean luc mélenchon a beaucoup de défauts
mais pas celui-là après loket par une au
journal du dimanche de l'institut
montaigne sur l'islam il ya eu
nombreuses positions et notamment celle
d'alain juppé qui a déclaré ne pas
accepter l'hystérie déraisonnable autour
de la question des musulmans quand il
parlait d'accommodation est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lui mais monsieur
juppé à plusieurs langages bon quand il
est devant valeurs actuelles il dit le
regroupement la fin du regroupement
familial
je l'avais proposé avant nicolas sarkozy
mais quand il est confronté à une
déclaration de nicolas sarkozy
eh bien il fait une autre déclaration de
calais alain juppé je vais je vais
croire celui qui quand il était premier
ministre nous a fait les lois debré ou
celui qui dit vous ne feriez pas
aujourd'hui on va trop loin sur ces
questions je ne sais pas lequel des deux
au fond je pense que je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure
nicolas sarkozy et alain juppé sont
d'accord ils se démarquent simplement
pour avoir un électorat que l'un ne peut
pas conquérir et que l'autre ne peut pas
non plus conquérir les un aveu conquérir
les centristes l'autre veut reconquérir
l'électorat du front national
tout ça c'est de l'électoralisme pour la
primaire qu'est ce que vous auriez
préféré
là où l'autre chacun s'est dit que
nicolas sarkozy ça favoriserait françois
hollande juppé se serait terminée vous
savez un alain juppé est friable en
campagne on le voit s'énerve vite les
personnels et oui on l'a vu récemment à
strasbourg
il est très rapidement à nouveau droit
dans ses bottes il a une position qui
n'est ni centristes ni droitière il est
attendu et là aussi il ya aussi
attaquable que nicolas sarkozy lui est
vraiment à la droite de la droite je
tiens à ces défauts et on va les
utiliser
vous voyez qui pardon vous voyez qui sur
cette primaire pour se voir rien du tout
j'ai lu que ça des prénoms du principal
parti de la majorité n'est pas moi qui
décide
faire un avis tôt politique mais comme
j'ai vu en lisant la presse de tous tout
dépendait du nombre de votants
comme je ne connais pas le nombre de
votants je ne peux pas répondre à votre
impertinente question la question de
cette séquence c'était ce qu'on
s'oriente vers un nouveau 21-avril votre
réponse c'est possible c'est possible
c'est possible que la gauche ne soit pas
au second tour c'est pour cela qu'il
faut tout faire pour la rassemblé apaisé
les tensions qui a pu avoir au sein de
la gauche
vous êtes d'accord pour dire avec le
chef de l'état dans l'interview au débat
que quel que soit le candidat qui sera
élu en 2017 il sera dans une situation
périlleuse parce que il sera élu avec
des électeurs qui se seront mobilisés
contre contre la présence du front
national donc une situation
en tout état de cause périlleuse pour le
prochain président de la république tout
à fait c'est la crise politique
française à partir du moment où vous
avez un front national qui tutoie les
30% pèse sur les débats
on le voit à droite et perturbe le
dispositif politique tel que nous le
nous l'avons connu jusqu'à présent
donc le problème qui résident toutes les
conséquences c'est que les candidats
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas avoir 50%
il faut qu'il soit le plus haut dans
leur couloir c'est l'élément de
totalement nouveau du tri parti le plus
haut dans le couloir pour françois
hollande sait combien c'est 30 % tant
que pur sang est arrivé au trône pourrez
écouter on a fait 25 % lors des
élections régionales on a fait 24 % lors
des élections départementales dans une
campagne on peut aller chercher 5% le
socle de françois hollande pour vous
c'est rôle pour se hisser le sait ce que
représente la gauche de gouvernement
dans le paysage politique
est-ce qu'elle sera mobilisable ou est
ce qu'elle sera mobilisée la réponse à
votre question sur le deuxième tour se
pose là et uniquement là merci jean
christophe cambadélis d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui pour 7,2
m éditions de l'épreuve de vérité on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine dont soir